I do want to get to my friend from NBC
Sports Boston to make heads or tails
about what happened yesterday
with Rob Gronkowski now joining Tom
Brady in Tampa Florida his name's Tom
Curren
how are you Tom I am great how are you
my friend I'm good I guess Edie
Gronkowski - who's not walking through
that door now huh without the Patriots
during this activity whether it's cross
or Brady or draft conversations like or
I mean it's fascinating and they have
been providing us so much content for
twenty years what are we gonna do rich I
know and it's been amazing and the Run
will be just as fascinating in the mouth
post Brady and Gronk era how long has
this caper been cultivated was this
always in the offing whenever Brady was
going to sign somewhere Tom that's a
great question and and I feel that there
was a dream team scenario that Brady was
trying to hatch I don't think that Brady
advised Cronk is his folks you know in
my office and on social media had
wandered to sit out last year I think
Gronk was really spent mentally need of
the year off needed to figure out what
he wanted to do and Brady backed off of
that but I believe that when Tom
realized okay I'm not coming back here
Cronk keep in the back pocket when I go
someplace let's see if we can get you
there I don't know what that was a
prerequisite for him signing anywhere
for instance if you went to San
Francisco with George kiddo was there
what they're going to get kron4
10-million I doubt it
but landing at Tampa opened up the door
rich I was caught completely flat-footed
I did not see this in the offing I think
this was a stealth move by Gronkowski
and what's fascinating to me is the
Gronkowski kind of out Bella checked
Bill Belichick on this what I mean so
many different ways what do you mean by
that he went on wildcat strike for a
year after Bill Belichick said he was
going to trade him in 2018 to the
Detroit Lions and Mark said I'm not
going subscribe Lyons I'll retire first
telecheck you have to reluctant to keep
him crock sticks around makes his money
wasn't happy all season long got another
ring retired but he did
retire officially until after the
Patriots quick kinda hosed in free
agency last year so after that he
retires Patriots are ala bucco and Jerry
cook they go through the season they
miss the hell out of crock den Krunk
this offseason waits until the Patriots
are in a situation where they have no
cap room and says you know what I'm
coming back
how's that but you can't afford me and
you have to trade me in the only place
she can trade me is Tampa Bay cuz I'm
not gonna go anyplace else so I think
it's so many ways you will think of the
man concedes and the Seymours and the
fray poles and the Theon branches and
the random losses and the evil Jamie
Collins who got bundled up and ship
someplace they didn't want to go
Belichick tried to do across the Detroit
and grunt didn't let that happen
he orchestrated something on at home I'm
with you here Tom and here I was in the
in the previous hours of this program
saying Belichick could have stood in the
way of this and by and said we're not
trading you but you're saying that Gronk
forced the situation by saying I'm sure
I'm on retiring and and made New England
trade him away otherwise what calling
his bluff would have been like we'll
just cut somebody and we'll get you on
the roster they could have done
something like they would have they
would have to cut ten million dollars
was a salary I mean grown to get they're
up against the cap as it is they have no
room so Gregg says okay I'm coming back
okay well we're not gonna trade you
you're our property okay I want to start
cutting people trade and Joe Tunney or
something like that a cut rate to get
him in and then maybe in three weeks
Francis you know what actually change
hard I'm gonna retire again sorry I mean
he could have played it out that way and
given the way Gronkowski and his family
have understood that they are a
collection of independent contractors
brought together as a team fighting over
a finite amount of money on every one of
these 32 franchises with the salary cap
I think that the business savvy of the
Gronkowski's
really oiled the gears to have this
happen it's it's genius it's kind of
crappy if you're a football fan but
Gronk Inc in the grant corporation got
what the crown corporation wanted Tom
Curren of NBC Sports Boston here on the
Rich Eisen show this is a fascinating
conversation is there anybody else to
get the band back together I'm serious
is there anybody else that's out there
that Brady's looking around and trying
to get his own guys in there that Tampa
I'm sure would say we can figure this
thing out because Tom makes Tom
comfortable and and they they all want
to win it's clearly the hot spot that
everybody wants to get in on if there's
any any more seats left on this ship
before it sets sails it sets sail
anybody else out there the only two guys
you could think of would be Amendola
Edelman Amendola is spoken for and
Edelman is under contract it Edelman is
so loyal
tavella's check anyway I couldn't
imagine him saying trade me ever ever it
would not be in his nature
despite his relationships so really who
else
I mean it's that's that's about it
unless they want to get Danny Woodhead
back I don't know they liked him it
sounds like the Blues Brothers you know
okay but no I think they're pretty
well-equipped what would the what this
does rich for Tampa Bay though is it
gives him a quick cheat code for Brady
to feel comfortable in Tampa with a
player he's so familiar with because if
Kovac wipes out the off season the
season begins and he hasn't spent time
with Evans and Godwin
he has spent so much time with
Gronkowski and Brady talks about this I
can tell Gronk
running full-speed downfield by the tip
of his shoulder or the lien of his head
what he's about to do and as a result
you're never gonna get that with Godwin
and Evans certainly not before this year
maybe ever in two years or three or four
however many there is but he's just done
something with Gronkowski and when you
look at Kronk what do you think he has
left I think he's gonna have plenty
what's your estimation
me oh yeah the guys you know what is he
30 31 I mean it's yeah he's got a year
off and he'll put the weight back on and
my gosh yeah this is what a godsend
I mean Grom could technically stay
longer if after Brady leaves if he
really likes it and he missed his
football and he I think him and Aryans
are gonna be just dynamite I mean seeing
Gronk without the worrying over his
shoulder what somebody might think of
what he says in the media are you
kidding me this is gonna be amazing
the NFL is a better place with Rob
Gronkowski in it in terms of being able
to cover it and enjoy it it is to me
it's it's fascinating what I you know
the interpersonal aspects of it to me
are gonna be fascinating because when
you look at Richard Seymour Mike for
able those are guys who were really
pissed Mankins too they kind of I buried
the hatchet with Belichick and you know
I think a player like Moss looks at it
now yeah I could have done it
differently but those other guys were
pissed they've all buried the hatchet
well Belichick be willing to bury a
hatchet with Gronkowski after again I'm
writing about this because I'm just
putting it together on my whole crap
Belichick must be Bulls crap no really
no kidding I mean deep deep down when
you think about it you know this dink
just took a year off you didn't tell us
until you know two weeks into free
agency wasn't coming blue-eyed she has
to get Jared cook because Jared Cook was
like hey what are you doing what's Gronk
doing in Buffalo this is last spring
it's like I don't want to come up there
and B 1 a 1 B was crunk you know I can
go to New Orleans and be there 1 a and
that was a deciding factor and then
Crocker weekly to goes yeah I'm out so
they didn't have a tight end at all last
year so it it's fascinating hmm
and of course that that helped lead to
Brady's departure when he was maybe
chafing under whatever was going on
there and this is why we have you on Tom
boots on the ground here from NBC Sports
Boston Tom Curren before I let you go
night before the draft what are you
hearing about the Patriots first-round
intentions and perhaps trading down
adding someone to the quarterback room
all of that Tom I give you the floor I
think a trade down makes the most sense
they have a huge hole because they have
no second round pick and this is such a
deep grass that they have an opportunity
to get back from that 23 spot and still
get multiple good players perhaps in the
second round and into the third day of
three ticks so they have some mobility
but everybody's trying to trade down if
they stay put rich they have so many
places they need help you know you could
go on the offensive line if Joe Tunney
is going to go elsewhere and you can get
a tackle when you can kick Isaiah went
inside on your left side and you have
two guys there they obviously could go
back to the well Y receiver Denzel Mims
my friend Phil parry has done an
unbelievable job for us on the draft is
there so is Pittman is sitting there as
well those are two two players you could
look at edge players they've said
goodbye to Trey flowers Jamie Collins
Kyle van Noy and really only have chase
twin of itch to try and bring pressure
to make the secondary that is aging
especially at the safety position really
as effective as it should be so there
are places all over this roster for the
Patriots to improve but I would probably
put my money cautiously on a trade town
okay thanks for the call to end its time
and it's still Stidham right it still
stood him it's gonna be his his ball
first week right at all personally I
wouldn't be stunned if you and Hertz was
a second-round pick of theirs I
personally like the kid Anthony Gordon's
from Mike Leach system just whipping it
all over the lot kind of the way Jimmy
Garoppolo came into the NFL same level
and styles play so those are two
quarterbacks who I dumbly take it for
what it's worth I'm about a c-grade
draft expert over here I'd say Hertz and
Anthony Gordon would be smart and if -
or drops your column today says don't
take that cheese what you're saying no
time ticket I think it's a horrendous
idea especially in the first round it's
it's a luxury item to pee
- crafted poorly for five years - it's a
luxury item because you don't know what
you have and there's so many question
marks around them beyond the hip beyond
the size he's been playing with the 33rd
NFL team for the last four years so
how's it gonna look on a team that just
lost Dantes Carnegie I might lose Joe
Tunney and every others did Tom Brady
didn't look good in 2019 find that
offensive line who was gonna yeah it
would not be great Tom thanks for the
call really appreciate it and and all
the information you'd be well we'll chat
on the other side of this draft how does
that sound
hope everything's great with you time is
right back at you that's Tom Curren at
Tom ecard on Twitter hey you watched all
the way to the end thanks for that watch
more right here